[Music]
after a Thursday night football game
years ago when Mike Wallace was
beginning to uh make noise about uh
wanting a new contract and the Steelers
saw something in this young man Antonio
Brown and it is paid off for the
Steelers as well as Antonio Brown
himself you remember that time when you
came on Thursday Night Football Antonio
absolutely absolutely how could I forget
that was a fun time right where you just
sit there and there's Dion there's
there's Irving was that your rookie
season no I think that was my second
year I think I came on set after
Cleveland game on Thursday night and how
many times have you been told you can't
in your career
Antonio
uh uh a lot of times you know uh but I
don't let it deter me you know I just
add fuel to the motivation adds fuel to
the motivation and so how how do you see
your your season going right now Antonio
well I gotta continue to get better um
got to continue to find ways to win and
be the reason why we win and um we got a
great opponent and a great matchup this
upcoming week in our house and uh we got
to find a way to be better what was it
like being part of a performance like
like the one that your quarterback put
on against
Indianapolis it an amazing experience
man to just have so much fun you know
and uh football is a game that made to
be fun and uh when you're having fun and
everybody on your team is excelling and
doing well it just uh bring energy in
the stadium that's uh quite an
experience and um when Ben is coming
into the week and you're seeing on film
a team that shut out Cincinnati did you
see something that you knew you could
exploit and you just went ahead and and
did it where did this come from
essentially well we just prepared you
know uh we believe we
prepare um the best way we can and uh
make sure we be in our best self uh we
knew we had opportunity and uh that's
exactly what we did we prepared and um I
guess hard work paid off and it's all
would you would you say this is last
week was just a continuation of what we
saw at the end of the first half against
Houston
Antonio uh I don't know I just think um
we continue to get better uh each and
every week uh this a midseason right now
and we got to continue to develop our
identity and car out our Niche and uh St
establish establishing what kind of team
we are see that you're talking about the
team that was my way of trying to get
you to say that you were the spark for
this entire turnaround with your
touchdown pass to Lance Moore
Antonio I'm trying to get to that I
guess you no you were not the spark to
this entire thing no man it's it's been
a great team effort you know the defense
okay produced some amazing turnovers
within like 90 seconds of the game the
previous week uh this week we had a pick
six a safety and um just uh feeding off
each other defense offense still got to
got to get it going and the Special
Teams but uh we just a team on the rise
and developing our identity what's that
like when you know you're in the middle
of a huge momentum swing on Monday Night
Football and you suddenly get the ball
back that you didn't expect it you go
into the huddle and you hear that play
called what was that like for you well
it's exciting you know I'm just ready to
make a play and ready to give a team the
opportunity to go up on the board and um
just hoping everyone doing their job so
as an 11 collectively we um succeed and
benefit off it now and and having sat
next to Deion Sanders for the nine years
that I've been fortunate to do that and
you you were there that night next to
Dion Antonio he has taught me that when
players step to the podium Dr dressed as
you were dressed after that game
bringing that outfit to work means that
you knew going into the game that you
were going to have a day would you agree
with that assessment seeing what you
were when you came correct on the
fashion front after that game Antonio
well you always got you always want to
look great and um every moment presents
a special moment and in those moments uh
you want to look apart and I believe
being a highly professional and a
fashion is confidence M and uh you look
good you play good I think uh Dion made
that know yes he did years way back yes
he did so do you have something special
from the closet for Sunday night for the
Ravens
absolutely can you can you give me a can
you give me a little fashion
forward yeah I got I got I got a couple
great options uh I uh got to put it
together okay so is this that's part of
your
pregame week routine is your you're are
you thinking now about Sunday's fashion
statement is we absolutely um I usually
have my girlfriend usually sort out a
couple looks for me and then um I try to
visualize and be thoughtful about them
how how I bring them out okay so you got
that working right now and then that's
cooking up okay that's cooking up and
because this is a pretty big G this is a
pretty big game Antonio you think about
it where you once were it's always big
with the Ravens coming in but this
division everybody's above 500 every
everybody is looking alive in this
division right now Antonio the big
Sunday night game you think about it yes
absolutely uh the competition is High um
the division is cooking up and it's time
that um it's the time of the year where
you start sorting yourself out and see
where you going to fall or what position
you're going to place at and um it's
great you know the competition kicking
up um everyone's at that 600 mid-range
and it's a great competition for the
division for NFL and for our
organization Antonio thank you for
joining me I appreciate it uh again it
was great meeting you that night at the
at the start of a career that is
blossoming before our very eyes congrats
on what you've been able to accomplish
now and good luck moving forward thank
brother thank R thanks for having me you
bet that's Antonio Brown right here on
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon
Eastern on
audience